[Music]
foreign
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive and tonight we're joined
by associate editor at the Daily Mirror
Kevin McGuire and Daily Mail columnist
Sarah Vine good evening to you both will
be with you in just a moment but first
let's have a look at what's on some of
those front pages
their last hope the Daily Star reports
that there's just hours left to find the
missing Titanic submersible as oxygen
supply dwindles
Rescuers have promised not to give up
hope of saving the five people on board
the vessel that that story on the front
page of the Metro too
The Daily Express reports saving the
five people on board rests with a rescue
robot being sent to the scene of the
search
the financial times reports that the
bank of England is under pressure to
raise interest rates by as much as half
a percentage point because of stubbornly
high inflation
the expected rate Rises sparking fears
of a recession that's the front cover of
the eye
Tori's turn on bank over rates crisis
that headline leads the daily mail
tomorrow
The Daily Telegraph reports lung cancer
tests will be offered to every ex-s
smoker to try and boost survival rates
security guards on a Kenyan apple farm
that supplies British supermarkets have
been accused of brutally assaulting and
killing people suspected of trespassing
on the property that exclusive story on
the front of tomorrow's Guardian
and reminded that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you're
watching us
and we're joined tonight by Kevin
McGuire and Sarah Vine great to see you
both thanks so much for joining us and
certainly inflation and interest rates
are very much dominating many of the
front pages uh Sarah to you first to buy
May let's look at the front page the
financial times stubborn inflation piles
pressure on Bank of England to take
tough action is their headline I mean
we've been talking about sticky
inflation haven't we but it really does
seem like it's stuck
very stuck um and of course Rishi wants
to get it down to three percent by the
end of the year which is looking
increasingly unlikely I suppose
um but the main issue for most people
will be interest rates because uh you
know we're a nation of homeowners and a
lot of people uh you know would have
borrowed
because interest rates have been
artificially low for so long they
probably borrowed more that they can
really afford
um and bought houses that were in
themselves inflated in price because of
the low interest rates so it's a sort of
pincer movement it's a kind of it's a
real horror show for uh homeowners and
um it's it's it's a really difficult
situation for the conservative party
because they are the party of home
ownership you know that's their
traditional space in the sort of
political Spectrum
um and you know you if you start to mess
with people's houses for most people
their home is their is their nest egg
it's the only real chance they have of
ever really making any money
saving anything and and now you're just
undermining all of that so rich is in a
very difficult position he's been and
he's been very clear he's going to um
he's going to keep trying to get these
rates you know this inflate station down
and that is going to have to mean more
interest rates Rises
it only feels that that's what we're
looking at uh tomorrow Kevin I mean it's
almost guaranteed isn't it that the bank
of England is going to raise interest
rates again tomorrow the question is by
how much
no no absolutely the decision will have
been taken they'll have had an early uh
site of the inflation data made their
decision and I think it's noon tomorrow
we'll get the bad news and of course the
ft is talking about a half percent uh
rise Rises used to be you know uh 0.25
uh but going up uh half percent half
percent that would be the five percent
December 2021 what that's just 19 months
ago the rate was 0.1 so it's absolutely
shot up as uh Sarah says it's it's
crucifying people with mortgages who
have to remortgage uh Kia starma at
premises questions had a very effective
attack on soon ad by talking about a 2
900 pound
um Tory mortgage penalty that's the
average figure the resolution believes
families will will have to pay
households will have to pay extra and he
promised to get inflation down and it's
it's stuck at 8.7 when I saw the figure
this morning I thought am I reading this
correctly because it was forecast to
fall but it's been forecast to fall
before and it's actually gone up this
time it didn't didn't fall so yes it's a
it's a huge political problem now for
the UK concert of government but more
importantly it is a massive Financial
headache for millions of families yeah
absolutely the front page of the eye
Sarah certainly is is predicting uh the
possibility of a recession mortgage pain
deepens there's new rate rise Sparks
recession fears uh talking about how the
base rate may now hit at six percent
next year and certainly this is just
going to mean a lot of pain for
homeowners 400 000 people are going to
have to renew their mortgages between
July and September
and also you've got people who will have
paid very high prices for their houses
and the mark and of course the housing
market will I mean some people are
saying that it could drop by as much as
30 in some places so you know you could
be sitting on a house this is just
brings back memories of of the 90s you
know that disaster is disastrous very
high interest rates and negative equity
and people having their homes
repossessed only in a funny kind of a
way it's worse now because back then we
hadn't had this long period of very low
interest rates which had artificially
inflated the housing market and made
people stretch themselves beyond their
natural capacity to buy and we've also
got another problem which is the rental
market is very is very very expensive at
the moment so people could be coming out
of their homes and not being able to
afford to rent plus the interest rates
are of course affecting the people who
have bought houses on buy to let
mortgages they will start not selling up
and that will cause cause problems for
tenants so it's not just a financial
problem it's it's a sort of Home problem
it's a home I mean we don't have enough
homes in Britain as it is uh and and and
you know places to rent and places to
buy are too expensive that could get a
lot worse yeah Kevin you hear older
homeowners talking about uh that period
that Sarah was referencing there where
interest rates went into double digits
and people were panicking overnight at
how they were going to be able to afford
their mortgages obviously we're not
seeing the same level of interest rates
but people are more exposed these days
in terms of how much they borrowed just
how do you think that could play out for
people this year
yeah I remember them going up for eight
to fifteen percent uh very very rapidly
and um and uh I'd got a fixed rate of
8.8 which I managed to see uh see it
through I was I was lucky if I remember
people having to take your lodges uh but
people just didn't have any any other
life because all they could do was pay
their their mortgage but at the time the
ratio between your wages and your
mortgage was a lot lower now because
house prices have been inflated for so
long and have risen so so quickly people
have got much bigger mortgages so so
they'll be hit even harder although it
won't be 15 you get five and six percent
that will proportionately be much harder
on them there'll be some people sitting
on paid off their mortgages they may you
know be able to ride it out they'll
their asset will just possibly go down a
little bit but there are just people
some people have to sell and downsize in
in a crisis so they won't get a good a
good price other people are just going
to see their family finances absolutely
wrecked they won't they won't be able to
eat out buy clothes go to events uh
holiday get new cars and that is where
the the I pick up on this this threat of
uh recession because the government says
high and high inflation is a big threat
to your living standards absolutely
absolutely is but at the same time if
the way to cure inflation is to actually
attack your living standards in another
Direction by putting pushing up not just
the cost of your mortgage but anything
you've got on a credit card or anything
else you've borrowed maybe bought that
car then you're going to get hammered in
a in another direction of course the big
push for information came from exterior
forces of Putin's invasion of uh of
Ukraine sending um oil and gas prices
soaring which fed through into into food
too and Britain has got a particular
problem because we import so much so
we've got higher inflation than the
other G7 major major economies but if if
the way of getting that inflation down
which has been pushed up mainly by
external factors is to hammer you at
home with interest rates then it just
seems crazy people are going to get
slapped uh from two different directions
and the economy can be crushed not much
of a cure is it if you're going to crush
the economy and certainly Sarah that
believer that we're going to see the
bank of England probably pulling again
tomorrow in terms of raising interest
rates just doesn't seem to be working
and this argument that it's a global
problem doesn't really necessarily ring
true anymore when you look at inflation
here in the UK which appears stuck at
more than eight percent and then you
look elsewhere China where it's
virtually non-existent the US is at four
percent Europe at six and certainly the
front page of your paper tomorrow is is
looking at the fact that some Tories are
turning on the bank of England over this
crisis
yes well of course now the blame game
starts and you know
um the two of the conservatives are
blaming Bank of England
uh you know uh kirst armor is obviously
going to make a lot of hey with this and
politically it makes perfect sense for
him to do so although I'm not I it
doesn't I'm not sure that labor has any
particular alternative
um it's going to be one of those
situations where everyone just blames
everybody else meanwhile ordinary people
suffer and also the other thing to say
is that I suppose back then in the 90s
people had more savings because as Kevin
was saying you know cost living was
lower you could put more money away you
were paying a smaller proportion of your
salary towards your uh your living costs
now people live on debt you know so so
and and you know they they borrow a lot
of everybody has borrowed far too much
in the last sort of 10 or 20 years and
so people don't have much of a cushion
and I think that's that's really going
to hit
um that's going to really it's going to
cost the conservatives very dear
electorally I think yeah certainly uh
it's going to potentially be costly for
them politically but people are far more
worried about how much is going to cost
them financially at the front page of
the Guardian
um Kevin is looking at Labor's calls for
mortgage support but certainly that's
something the government has ruled out
they're not going to offer Financial
intervention for mortgage holders
because they say it'll be inflationary
no no absolutely absolutely an expensive
uh they say but Rachel Reeves the shadow
uh treasury secretary latest Chancellor
in Waiting really is is calling calling
for help one of the proposals is to
extend mortgage repayment uh periods
well that works if uh your your pain
largely Capital off but if you're in the
early part of your mortgage all at
almost all the money you go obviously
you've got a 25-year mortgage goes on
interest and you can pay a lot each
month and all you all you really
actually buy is a couple of bricks I
remember watching uh you know my own
Mortgage fall very very slowly at at the
uh at the start because of it because
most of the money was on the interest
and it wasn't on the capital so this can
only bail you out to to some extent and
only and only some people I mean the
truth is there is no easy is the answer
the Metro pick up on renters uh two it's
not just people with mortgages 21 months
the rents increases of outstripped uh
inflation generally and they reckon now
if you're outside London the average
renter we mustn't forget you know the
government is in serious trouble when
it's got homeowners or home buyers and
it's got renters boats coming at it
outside of London the average rent now
is 1136 pounds a month and in London
more than two thousand pounds more than
two thousand pounds is 24 000 pounds a
year that's 24 000 pounds cash that's
after tax and National Insurance so
you'd be talking around getting on for
for 30 000 pounds a year you would have
to be earning growth just to pay your
rent so
labor I suppose and the liberal
Democrats and others in opposition uh
I've got proposals but I'm not sure they
will fundamentally address a problem
which is rents are far too high and now
people are going to be absolutely
crucified by Rising mortgages yes it is
certainly such a worrying time for so
many people Kevin Sarah thanks so much
we'll see you again in just a sec uh
more for the front pages coming up after
this break uh including this front page
of the telegraph Titanic sub-operator
too slow to raise the alarms that the
time is running out in that rescue
operation we'll be talking about that
after this short break
[Music]
thank you
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview on Sky News it's good to have
you with us and with me this evening is
the associate editor at the Daily Mirror
Kevin McGuire and the Daily Mail
columnist Sarah Vine and of course the
other big story on so many of the front
pages once again tomorrow Kevin is this
missing submersible with five people on
board missing uh since Sunday and
certainly time is running out
no I absolutely absolutely with the uh
the oxygen as you're saying some papers
say 11 others say 12 noon
um sounds are being picked up
but they don't even know where it is
never mind trying to to get it up so
while you always hope for the best I
think uh I think now it's a case of
fearing uh fearing the worst and
there'll be lots of questions I asked I
I have picked up
um I was slightly surprised but some
people are not too sympathetic to the
group uh believing they spent a lot of
money on tourism and it was incredibly
dangerous and they should have gone
um and there are other arguments about
why do these five get so much coverage
and the bigger disasters possibly
including 750 people on a ship in the
Mediterranean that went down why don't
they get as much coverage but you just
really you just kind of see the drama of
it but you also they the Heartbreak of
the families knowing that these five
people
are trapped in this this fight against
time uh that isn't on their side yeah
absolutely it doesn't really bear
thinking about but it certainly has
captured the attention of the world uh
Sarah and I was speaking to uh someone
earlier who was on for an interview who
used to be in the U.S Navy and he said
that even if the worst case scenario is
if they found them at this stage or on
the seabed they don't actually have the
equipment yet in place to pull them up
um and certainly there's already
criticism in the telegraph uh in an
article on it on page one tomorrow
um that they were too slow to raise the
alarm here in this rescue operation
yes I mean the thing is even if they as
as you say even if they get to them
because the thing is sealed with 17
bolts or something they can't even get
more oxygen in and of course they can't
raise them up quick enough
um to to open this up so it's it's a
very sad and difficult situation
um
you know I I I I it's it's an old thing
I I you know I I can't understand why
anybody who wants to do something like
that let alone spend 250 000 pounds
doing it but
um you know we we've sent fewer people
to the bottom of the ocean than we have
into outer space it's a very very
hostile environment and
um there you know there have been
concerns raised about this operation
before
um so you know it's I think the reason
it's captured the imagination so much is
because it is it is a Race Against Time
isn't it to try and get them out and of
course the Titanic is is a sort of
eternally fascinating sea wreck
um but I just you know it seems very sad
I I I I feel terrible for their families
yeah absolutely
um but certainly the message is loud and
clear they are not giving up hope at
this stage for as long as there is a
time left then there's hope but it's
estimated there could be as little as 14
hours of oxygen left it doesn't bear
thinking about Kevin Sarah thanks so
much we'll see you again next hour